this is another great recipe you can
stake your life on
it's my homemade crumpet
whether you're cooking for two three or
even a gang some of the best brunch
dishes are always the simplest
these crumpets are absolutely delicious
and it's a great end to a fantastic
brunch
first off we're gonna make the mix
when you think of
growing up
the smell
and the taste of amazing crumpet
it never leaves you to make the mix the
secret is to bring the milk up the ball
but do not boil it the minute it boils
turn it off and let it sit there now
flour in
a nice pinch of salt
in now add half a teaspoon of bicarb
that gives it aeration and really lifts
the mixture up all those lovely little
holes a nice pinch of sugar
and then
a teaspoon of yeast dry yeast
now once the milk's boiled turn it off
and add some warm water
about 10 tablespoons 150 ml
that cools down the milk
but more importantly it doesn't destroy
the yeast
half
of the milk in first stop
and give that a really good mix
now the rest of it
[Music]
[Music]
you can just see that there's no lumps
through there as it drips through the
whisk now we're looking for it to double
in size and get nice and light
so pop in a warm place whilst you get on
with the delicious topping
[Music]
beautiful strawberries but caramelised
almost like a very quick strawberry jam
hang on
[Music]
just
slice these
in half
some sugar a couple of tablespoons
we're gonna take the sugar to a nice
light caramel it's just starting to
change color now
turn the gas down and we're gonna add
the strawberries
beautiful
just sweating the strawberries down
quickly and the caramels breaking down
a wonderful glaze
on the strawberries
some lemon
grated into the strawberries
gives it that kind of freshness
that really
starts to break down the strawberries
nice
gas up
smells incredible some lemon juice
a touch of balsamo vinegar
in that gives it that really nice
delicious tartness now
off it goes
as the strawberries start to cool down
it will naturally thicken and
set beautifully
nice
[Music]
now for the crumpet
it's almost doubled in size but be very
careful you don't knock the bowl because
it can sort of push out all that air
it's aerated it's nice it's light
just see
the texture
she's ready to go
did you boil it
here we go
instead of making normal small crumpets
i'm making a giant one ideal for sharing
now turn the gas down
you just start to see
a traditional crumpet style cooking
process we want those nice tiny little
holes on top and then crispy crunchy
base
right now
it's time to add the butter just slide
the butter
down the back
that gives it a really nice nutty flavor
at the end
fish nice
flip
beautiful
take that out
take the jam
spoon
the secret is for the juice to sort of
run inside all those little holes
think of that tartness of the
balsamic vinegar the strawberries
beautifully
soft
and almost pureed
wrapped
in that delicious caramel
now
finish that
with a nice ball of creme fraiche
and let that
sit there
and that
is an amazing way of finishing off a
traditional brunch
with something sweet something delicious
and something you're dying to tuck into
[Music]
soft fiery and irresistible spicy
pancakes
one of the secrets to good cooking is
learning to use your imagination when it
comes to brunches you don't have to
stick to the old standbys these
delicious spicy pancakes are really
great alternative but more importantly
so easy to do
start off by toasting your cumin
[Music]
it's a dry roast basically non-stick pan
just a touch of seasoning
the salt helps to dry out the cumin even
more
and then fresh ginger slice them nice
and thinly
stack it back up
and then just slice nice little thin
slices in there
and then keep that bunched up
shake the chilli
removing the seeds will prevent things
getting too hot
now
garlic
nice now
add olive oil to your toasted cumin
seeds and then with the garlic ginger
and chili lovely
[Music]
and it feels strange when you talk about
garlic for breakfast but the time i
spent in india
everybody was eating something savory
for breakfast it was extraordinary
into your bowl
and set aside
next the pancake filling add olive oil
to a hot pan
mustard seeds in now they'll start
dancing the minute they hit the pan
then finely slice an onion
onions in
a little teaspoon of turmeric sprinkle
that in
and look at the color
an instant change
leftover potatoes
just slice them
the smell is incredible potatoes in now
spread the potatoes across the pan on
the potatoes stained i want them sort of
absorbing all that really nice turmeric
actually like a sponge
season those potatoes and it really
helps to bring out
the spice beautifully
they're ready
turn off the gas and let them sit there
and absorb all those flavors
back to the pancake batter add plain
flour to your cooled garlic chili ginger
and cumin seeds
touch with salt
and pepper nothing worse than the bland
pancake
one whole egg
milk
hold the jug with one hand and whisk we
have a secret to get that really nice
smooth paste
but
whisking that egg first and brings it
together
and then you're milking
don't put all the milk in because then
you're gonna get a lumpy pancake mix
and if you put less milk in
it really helps it
not going lumpy
look at that
milk here
and the secret for me is to have a nice
thin mix
now just
a little teaspoon
of oil that helps to bring
a nice crispy edge to the mixture
now just taste
that's the texture pan on
the larger the pan the better it helps
to create a nice thin even surface i
want that mix going all the way around
the pan before you put the mixture into
the pan make sure you give your pancake
mix a really nice stir
pan it's nice and hot
turn down the gas
a touch of olive oil in get that nice
whisk with one hand
pan to the mix
in
one and a half ladles and then roll it
around so it's really nice and thin i
want to see the ginger the garlic that's
what i'm looking for
in there now back onto the heat it only
starts to remove from the bottom of the
pan and lifts itself up once it's cooked
these little bubbles
confirm that it's just starting to lift
off
the pan
a little shake that releases it and then
just shake it to the end
and toss if you haven't got the
confidence tossing then use a spatula
and turn it over now
that's exactly what i want that nice
sort of crisp edge around the side the
color on the pancake is so important
now
roll it round
and just let it slide out
beautifully
now
for the exciting part filling them
take your potatoes
just sort of
have a really nice imaginary line
and then just very carefully
roll that
nice
and tightly tuck it underneath there
pull it back
and roll
useful
the delicious pancakes are ready to eat
but with a simple dipping sauce there'll
be a real treat just mix chopped
coriander with natural yoghurt
that's really nice cooling asian sit
there on the side
and that for me is a great brunch
delicious spicy pancakes
amazing
you